[Music]
hello we are and these are our favorite
snacks oh yeah let's go let's
go that oh oh we a chopck
oh who snack is this
[Music]
it smells like my mother's
manicure you're supposed to open these
with like toothpicks like you got to
poke them
[Music]
get on
cam apparently you don't need toothpast
there's a warning sign you got to bite
them or else it's going to get stuck on
your throat
[Music]
like
M it's good sweet sweet oh
yeah oh my
God thank you are you okay
M better than I
thought
[Music]
ohab is my favorite snake oh really jaab
is Japanese Jaga is potato and B is
snack
po I'm going to CH it just a little bit
light salt oh perfect
ASMR you you got to put the hand behind
the focus I know in front of
it okay let's try it smell
first it's like french fries it's like
chips even though they're Japanese
snacks these are really popular popular
pretty popular I think we all had some
okay that
wasab yeah chab what yeah what is it
best P ever C cnab
cereal Cinnabon is one of my favorite
childhood snacks when I was young if my
memor is right is from my yeah Hometown
Seattle and my mother always gave this
to me when I it's very meaningful for me
and also good a c two two come on come
on come on come
on oh
man
wa wow oh just smell it oh just smell it
just smell
it just smell
wow
it tastes like
TR toet
toet all time
Legend ham cheese toasty
cheese who's snack guys my snack is a
ham and cheese toasty with a barbecue
sauce the one thing that is different is
like it's not pressed much like in
Australia you got to press it you got to
squish it yeah like and one thing it's
supposed to be cut in a triangle
triangle rectangle you have a lot of
details about it looks pretty good but I
want to add in ketchup B ketchup that's
why that's why we have a wow thank you
this brand if you don't know this you're
know
Australian made in Australia this
barbecue sauce you can't have it with
anything you can put in the cereal if
you want it's so good
anything I'll try it do you have a
ketchup you got to all try it you got to
dip it yeah
[Music]
absolutely
sck I used to have this a lot when I was
in school at lunch good at
school
wow going to Japan now
[Music]
yeah how do you guys get all
this you're really looking like what is
that Nat K it has a really strange
texture so some people like it but some
people don't like it it's a bit for me I
don't really enjoy this but some people
but if you like it you'll have it in
every morning is this one I need
rice just try a little bit mix 27 Oh
detail 27 mix it 27 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11
[Music]
rice I'm okay I brush
my I'm
good my favorite M why very delicious
sweet wow is brighter than the Korean
one yeah these are real these are real
I'm I'm good I'm
fine why actually I could be CH cha CH I
mean we don't need to eat this we
already brushed our teeth yeah but
brushing the teeth okay JY try
it I can't tell this is delicious but
yeah it's not bad not that bad better
than you
think wow
[Music]
about two years ago we just delivered
this for our practice time in every day
so yeah it's kind of practice drink yeah
we you good to
milk he's really big fan of milk
[Music]
tea this has
been and we showed you our favorite
snacks and also we came out with a new
album called orang blood so please
stream that all platforms available
let's
go thank
[Music]
you